foreign
what's up Edward
just rocking on to the break of dawn
John how are you ask me too me too
except it's like the middle of the
morning but the party never stops Snoop
Dogg what's up man
I'm actually kidding I've got two kids
so when they're sleeping I'm sleeping
and even when they're awake I'm sleeping
uh good for you man um
so the question comes up from uh some
lightning round questions you did about
marriage and
the question was how do you maintain
intimacy with small kids at home and you
know you said we don't and if you've got
two kids five and under it's a sex-free
zone for a long time and I've got two
kids under five so one's five and the
other one's two yes
um
you know I was you know I was kidding
right for it I was kidding yes I know
okay good all right and then you went on
to explain you know how you plan it and
schedule it okay cool and so
um you know my wife and I we have
certain forms of intimacy that we you
know holding hands and hugging and
kissing and we do that all in front of
the kids
um to show what a husband and a wife
looks like you know a healthy
relationship
so the question becomes you know how do
we help our kids understand that
those boundaries are for for married
couples and adult
um you know hugging your mom and your
dad and your grandparents is okay but
say like your friends and your teacher
you don't just go up and give them a hug
and a kiss it's not
it's that type of affection is for
um certain people
is
is that happening or are y'all worried
about that happening
um so at daycare one time our oldest had
hugged and gave a kiss to another kid so
that happened once okay
um and I I it hasn't happened
otherwise but
it's a concern okay I I would not lose a
single
ounce of sleep over that not for one
second
there tends to be a
um socialization that limits that
um occasionally there are kids that are
over affectionate and
um it's as simple as hugs and kisses or
for family members
hugs and kisses are for very very close
friends and we ask permission so
something s like low level
is not always but occasionally my wife
will say can I have a morning hug
I always ask my daughter for permission
to give her a hug
um and I'm trying to teach her that
she's in control of her body
um if my wife and I do hug in the
morning in front of the kid it's like a
big demonstrative thing but I also want
to caution you against this
don't use each other as a chalkboard
meaning hug your wife because you love
love your wife
ask your wife
um
like
can I have a hug
um can I give you a big kiss like do
that because you want to kiss your wife
not because you want to demonstrate what
a healthy marriage is if you truly and
deeply engage in Acts of intimacy both
behind closed doors and in front of
closed doors with your spouse
that comes the lesson comes through but
when you make each other an object
lesson it really can get wonky quick
because you start wondering why
someone's doing something or are they
doing it on purpose you see what I'm
saying it starts getting messy and so I
would lean directly into that I I
wouldn't worry about that one second I I
I'm making the data up here but I would
say 95 percent of kids
um are gonna hug each other they're
gonna hold hands they're going to
um be close with one another they're
gonna bang and bonk into each other
because they're trying to establish
space in relational space and that's
that is why I like school that's there's
some socialization there this is
appropriate here not appropriate here
um but on the whole most kids understand
they have a innate sense of safety with
their home crew that makes hugs and
other things more okay than in other
places and then occasionally I've had to
have conversations with my kids I worked
with one family
um
and their son was big for his age and he
was
um
like always ending up playing with
younger kids and then they had built a
huge like Fort like a fort on one of the
kids beds at a neighbor's house and the
neighbor had like three young girls
and so they didn't know how to have the
conversation with this younger boy I
think he was nine or ten hey it's
inappropriate for you to be under the
covers with three little girls and he he
simply couldn't understand it it wasn't
even in his head and so we had to talk
about appropriate right it's not
appropriate with other people's so that
was just a simple we we they called me
and I walked him through how to have
that conversation ended up being hard
harder than they thought but but overall
simple just address the behavior as it
happens
okay
sure
um are you you're you're not this is all
you're just worried about this happening
down the road
kind of yeah and I guess
once was we were out front in our yard
you know watering collars or something
in a nice little old lady walked by and
and as she was passing the boys are just
like I want to go give her a hug so they
ran up to her and and gave her hug and
stuff and I was like okay that was it it
was really sweet but also it's like okay
well who who are they always gonna want
to give hugs to in certain
um things like that so that is that's a
if you find your kids like at a Walmart
giving hugs to tons of strangers
that's when you have a quiet
conversation this isn't an appropriate
place and you can point back to you
um Mommy and Daddy give each other hugs
Daddy hugs his friends at at work or
Daddy hugs his friends when they come
over my son sees me hug other men
regularly
my son sees me hug my friend's wives and
um women that I'm close to that I'm
friends with they don't see me kiss them
right and so I can point back to me as a
model for I hug Mr Todd and I hug Mr
John and I hug Mr Nathan I don't hug
strange men at Walmart
because I don't know them and I don't
have that sort of it's right so these
are these are gentle teaching moments
also if they say I want to go give that
old woman a hug
all you have to say is make sure you ask
her for her permission that's it and let
him go run and they can run on the
street and she can say no thank you or
she she can have her entire world made
because two little boys can't give her a
hug right
um right and so that's what my wife had
said is you don't know what kind of day
she was having that could have just made
her whole day I I would be willing to
bet it did but I do like the practice of
um whenever I'm at book signings or I
was just in Dallas for a huge event
thousands of people people came up and
they really quickly like I'm signing
their book and they really quickly will
say something heavy like I was thinking
about suicide and I got your book and it
helped or I was in a really abusive
relationship and you're you gave me the
courage to step out I'll often look at
them and I'll say can I give you a hug I
never hug somebody without especially a
stranger without asking you permission
can I give you a hug male female I don't
care who
um police officer to an elderly Grandma
right I asked the permission and I think
that's a great thing to model for your
sons what we don't want to do is I don't
want to take away that inclination for
hugging for human connection human touch
I don't want that to be registered in
their little Minds as bad or as of
something to avoid I think that that's
one of the things in our culture that's
killing us
I I may have talked about this on the
show one of the places I worked years
ago during the HR onboarding process
they recommended the air high five
and I was like what
and there was like 50 of us in this in
this onboarding meeting and they said
yeah if if one of your colleagues does
something great gets a huge Grant or
gets a publication we recommend the air
high five to avoid confusion
and I was like what kind of confusion
and he's like just we want to avoid
unwanted touch
and I was like man there are some
creepers who have just blown it for
everybody and what we've created is a
completely Touch free society and I
don't think that's ever existed before
and there are people who abuse touch
right that's look go back and read the
metoo transcripts man of bosses who slap
people on the butt or who hug too much
or grope a little like so it's
disgusting so we gotta strike a balance
we gotta teach our kids a modeling is
the best but B
um I don't want them to learn that touch
is bad I want them to to learn there's
an appropriate touch and there's a
welcome touch and there's an unwelcome
touch right I don't think you're
anywhere near that right now I think
with just one or two sentences
um one or two go make sure you ask is it
okay for to give you a hug
man what a great gift you're teaching
your sons which is they know that their
touch to that old woman is therapeutic
and healing and life-giving and they
asked for consent which I think is
important
sure as everyone's been doing I guess
yeah and we haven't been doing the ask
for consent but usually like when we say
goodbye to let's say a grandparent or
something we say do you want to go give
so-and-so a hug and then they yes and go
run up and give a hug so yeah hey we'll
make sure let me tell you this let me
tell you this that's huge
um I really am grossed out when a
Grandpa's like come give me a kiss and
the the granddaughter says no thank you
you're gonna go kiss your grandad nope
like and I a good for you do you asking
your children do you want to go give
Granddad a hug do you want to give
grandma a hug before she goes
um I'm going to give grandma a hug do
you want to come with me I think that's
phenomenal because you're letting the
kid have body autonomy and you're
letting them have it and
um letting them take ownership of their
body and they're watching you do it good
for you man you're right on track
brother
all right yeah way to go man um parents
hug your sons hug your daughters and
invite them into that and a little
vocalization doesn't hurt
um it's welcoming hey hun can I give you
a big hug this morning
um
I I think that's a gift to your kids
um and teaching them about consent is
awesome good for you good for you